[Aplausos]
[Música]
en españa tiene el dudoso honor de ser
líder mundial en una cosa paro juvenil
habéis oído bien el 40 por ciento de los
jóvenes españoles está en el paro los
únicos países que superan españa en este
asunto en el mundo son lugares tampoco
ejemplares como armenia sudáfrica o la
franja de gaza como os podéis imaginar
esto no es un problema más es el
problema uno de los grandes problemas de
españa y no penséis que hablamos
solamente de paro pensando bien cuatro
de cada diez menores de 25 años españa
no tiene trabajo y eso se traduce en
pobreza y desigualdad si en este vídeo
vamos a hablar de desigualdad desde una
perspectiva que os va a sorprender a
todos
[Música]
puede que sorprenda pero españa es el
tercer país con más diferencias entre
ricos y pobres de toda europa sólo está
superado por países también poco
ejemplares como rumanía y bulgaria
seguramente os parezca difícil de creer
verdad españa tiene un estado del
bienestar grande por ejemplo es un país
que se toma tan en serio la brecha de
género que hasta tiene un ministerio
dedicado a la igualdad es decir que hay
un ministerio entero dedicado a en
principio limar las desigualdades entre
hombres y mujeres hablamos de un tema
discutido hasta la saciedad en todos los
medios de comunicación sin embargo aquí
están los datos el 26 por ciento de las
mujeres españolas están en riesgo de
pobreza frente al 24 6% de los hombres
vamos que hay una diferencia pero no es
tan grande sin embargo vamos a mirar la
desigualdad por edades
[Música]
en este caso el 33% de los menores de 18
años en españa está en riesgo de pobreza
frente al 17 7 por ciento de los mayores
de 65 años dicho de otra manera que si
nos vamos a los datos el auténtico
problema de españa no es la desigualdad
por género sino por edad y creedme no
hablamos de un problema hablamos de el
problema y el auténtico elefante en la
habitación que está impidiendo que
españa pueda crecer puede recuperarse de
la crisis y del que prácticamente ningún
medio de comunicación había hablado
antes atentos a esta imagen
lo que estáis viendo aquí es saturno
devorando a sus hijos de francisco de
goya se trata de una de las imágenes más
icónicas de la pintura española puede
que resulte un tanto desagradable pero a
tenor de los datos podemos decir que el
sistema político de españa es un saturno
gigante que está devorando sus pueblos
para alimentar una red de intereses
creados dicho de otra forma el auténtico
conflicto en españa' no es madrid contra
cataluña ni tampoco hombres contra
mujeres por mucho que muchos medios
empeñan en eso el auténtico conflicto en
españa' es el que existe entre los
nacidos entre los años sesenta los
llamados boomers y los nacidos a partir
de los años ochenta es decir los
millennials y los tummers y ya se lo que
estáis pensando muchos venga ya fonseca
desde cuando hacéis análisis tan simples
en visual político de verdad vas a
contarnos ahora que en españa hay un
conflicto de clase entre millenials
contra boomers de verdad vas a contarnos
que españa es un país tan injusto hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
ok comer
los que veáis este vídeo desde españa
seguramente habréis oído hablar de este
término los llamados ni-nis es decir
gente que ni estudia ni trabaja cada vez
es más normal encontrar españoles que
viven con sus padres hasta los 30 años o
incluso más seguramente muchos de los
que estéis viendo este vídeo desde
españa estéis en esta situación o
tengáis algún amigo que lo esté esto es
un problema si queremos comparar la
renta de los millennials con la renta de
los boomers pensadlo bien la renta se
suele medir por hogares es decir no por
individuos y la mayoría de estos
millennials que tienen cero ingresos
viven con sus padres que si tienen
trabajo por esta razón en visual
política hemos tenido que hacer nuestra
propia estimación esta estimación está
hecha en base al salario medio por
edades combinada con la tasa de paro
pues bien atentos a esta gráfica
[Música]
como podéis ver los mayores de 60 años
ganan de media casi 3 veces más que los
menores de 25 años pero esto es solo una
estimación muy probablemente esta
desigualdad sea muchísimo más grande y
grace porque pues porque tendríamos que
tener en cuenta otras vías de ingresos
como dividendos por acciones o rentas de
los alquileres para que os hagáis una
idea según el propio informe eespaña
2050 publicado por el gobierno los
mayores de 65 años tienen un patrimonio
acumulado que es hasta cinco veces mayor
que los de 35 años hablamos del mismo
nivel de desigualdad que existe en eeuu
habéis oído bien eeuu es un país
conocido por tener unas desigualdades
enormes pues bien en lo que a brecha
generacional respecta españa tiene un
problema similar al de eeuu o incluso
peores
[Música]
porque vamos a ser claros parte de la
desigualdad que tiene el país de las
barras y estrellas se debe a que también
tienen una enorme población de
multimillonarios que distorsionan
cualquier media que queramos hacer el
caso de españa- es muy distinto porque
no existe una población tan grande de
millonarios sin embargo sí que podemos
hablar de unos 'insiders' que disfrutan
de todos los privilegios de un sistema
construido a su medida y unos outsiders
que lo sufren y diréis pero quiénes son
nuestros 'insiders' pues claramente los
mayores de 60 años es decir aquellos
nacidos en la década de los años 60 los
años 60 fueron los años del baby boom en
españa'
hablamos de la generación más numerosa
de este país muchos de ellos ya son
pensionistas otros de ellos son
funcionarios y otros trabajan en lo que
podríamos llamar el sector de los
gigantes y diréis pero qué quieres decir
con eso del sector de los gigantes pues
bien hablamos de las empresas más
grandes de españa en esta categoría
entran las principales empresas
energéticas los principales bancos o
empresas como telefónica estas compañías
contratan a más de medio millón de
españoles y muchos de sus trabajadores
más veteranos gozan de condiciones muy
pero que muy especiales atentos
[Música]
manny por no hacer
tanto si veis este vídeo desde españa
como si lo veis desde latinoamérica
todos conoceréis una empresa que se
llama telefónica hablamos de un coloso
de las telecomunicaciones a nivel
internacional lo que tal vez no sepáis
es que hubo una época en la que
telefónica era una empresa estatal es
decir telefónica era propiedad del
estado español hasta el año 1997 fue en
ese año cuando el gobierno de españa'
privatizó telefónica como os podéis
imaginar los sindicatos protestaron con
uñas y dientes así que el gobierno de
aquel entonces tuvo que pactar un
acuerdo muy generoso con los sindicatos
sin embargo telefónica lleva décadas
despidiendo a gente para que os hagáis
una idea en el año 2016 las oficinas
españolas de telefónica tenían 33 mil
400 empleados cuatro años más tarde en
2020 telefónica españa había reducido su
plantilla en 22 mil 900 personas y
diréis esto deben ser las noticias para
los trabajadores verdad pues nada de eso
atentos el 10% de la plantilla de
telefónica a casa con 53 años y el 70
por ciento del sueldo esta noticia desde
el año 2019
en este caso telefónica despidió a más
de 2.600 trabajadores pero las
condiciones eran las siguientes atentos
si llevabas más de 15 años trabajando en
la empresa y tenías más de 53 años te
daban el 68 por ciento del sueldo hasta
que cumplieron los 65 años que es la
edad de jubilación es decir que hablamos
de una media de 1.500 euros al mes mil
quinientos euros al mes que hay gente
que está cobrando en este momento haga
lo que haga es decir que pueden buscarse
otro trabajo montar su propia empresa y
seguir cobrando esa pensión tan jugosa
de telefonía pero esperado momento
porque este no es un caso aislado en el
momento no que hacemos este vídeo nature
y que es una de las principales
energéticas de españa ha hecho otro
ajuste de plantilla en este caso han
llegado a pagar atentos hasta seis años
de sueldo a algunos trabajadores no sé
si os dais cuenta de las cifras que
manejamos pero estoy un ejemplo imaginad
a una persona que trabaja en nature gym
y cobra 55 mil euros al año esto es un
sueldo bastante habitual para cargos
intermedios pues bien si esta persona se
marcha de la empresa puede llegar a
cobrar una indemnización de hasta 340
mil euros habéis oído bien con esto te
puedes comprar un piso en españa' en
prácticamente cualquier ciudad y en
buena medida esto es el resultado de
años de convenios sindicales pero ya sé
lo que estaréis pensando mucho dónde
está el problema
tarde o temprano todas estas empresas
necesitarán contratar a todos esos
millennials que están en el paro verdad
pues si tenéis razón el problema el
problema es que no lo hace y aquí es
cuando llegamos al siguiente actor de
nuestra historia las consultoras
[Música]
imaginad que sois un directivo de
telefónica contratar a un trabajador
nuevo supone un riesgo enorme si lo
queréis despedir podéis terminar pagando
cientos de miles de euros como ya hemos
visto y diréis no existe una solución
más barata pues lo cierto es que sí y
esa solución son las consultoras dicho
de otra forma nosotros como telefónica o
como gran empresa no contratamos a más
trabajadores lo que hacemos es pagar a
una empresa para que los contraté esta
empresa no ha firmado ningún convenio
con ningún sindicato así que pueden
contratar y despedir a gente sin tener
que pagar esas indemnizaciones
millonarias es decir que si un día vais
a una oficina de telefónica encontrareis
a mucha gente joven trabajando pero
desde un punto de vista legal el
empleador de toda esa gente no es
telefónica sino una empresa mucho más
pequeña y todo esto explica la siguiente
gráfica
[Música]
lo que estáis viendo ahora es el
porcentaje de trabajadores temporales en
españa' comparado con el resto de la
unión europea como podéis ver la
diferencia es abismal en el resto de
europa los contratos temporales son una
anomalía porque pues porque la mayor
parte de la gente trabaja a tiempo
indefinido en españa' sin embargo la
norma para prácticamente todos los
menores de 35 años es trabajar como
temporal y si no me creéis no tenéis más
que mirar la sección de comentarios de
este vídeo estoy convencido de que
estará llena de españoles que están en
esta misma situación pero la pregunta la
auténtica pregunta es de verdad queremos
solucionar todo esto y si os dijera que
esa desigualdad es algo buscado atentos
porque ahora vamos a llegar a la parte
del vídeo que os va a dejar helados
el ejército industrial de reserva
en el año 2010 un grupo de 100
economistas españoles firmaron el
llamado manifiesto de los 100 entre
otras muchas cosas proponían dos medidas
para acabar con la temporalidad laboral
el contrato único y la mochila austriaca
y diréis en qué consistían estas medidas
pues muy sencillo el llamado contrato
único consiste en que todos los
trabajadores tendrían los mismos
derechos y la misma protección es decir
que en lugar de tener a trabajadores
indefinidos por un lado y temporales por
el otro todo el mundo se consideraría
como trabajador indefinido por su parte
la mochila austriaca significa que en
vez de tener una indemnización por
despido el trabajador acumularía una
especie de cuenta de ahorros una
cantidad que la empresa le abonaría
mensualmente de esta forma aunque la
empresa no te despida y te vayas porque
quieres no pierdes la compensación por
despido porque lógicamente el ahorro
acumulado lo seguirías manteniendo
[Música]
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando esta
propuesta aparece la clásica propuesta
que defendería un sindicato y que
criticar a un empresario verdad pues
aquí es donde viene la auténtica
sorpresa el excepcionalismo español si
la política española puede parecernos
muy polarizada parece imposible llegar a
ningún consenso sin embargo en el año
2012 tanto la izquierda como la derecha
fueron capaces de llegar a un acuerdo
todos dijeron no al contrato único
gobierno patronal y sindicatos rechazan
la implantación del contrato único y ya
sé lo que estaréis pensando mucho espero
dónde está el problema porque nadie
quiere que todos los trabajadores tengan
las mismas condiciones podemos hacer
muchas conjeturas pero los números
hablan por sí solos atentos a esta
gráfica
este gráfico representa las variaciones
de desempleo entre boomers y millennials
la línea roja representa a los menores
de 25 años la línea azul representa a
los mayores de 55 como podéis ver los
boomers han sufrido la crisis muchísimo
menos que los millennials y los zoom ers
dicho de otra forma que mientras haya
gente con contratos temporales a la que
se puede despedir fácilmente los boomers
pueden dormir tranquilos
pensando así volvamos a imaginar que
somos ese directivo de telefónica y
tenemos que hacer recortes de plantilla
tenemos que reducir costes y tenemos que
despedir a 2.000 trabajadores si de
repente todos los trabajadores tuvieran
el mismo tipo de contrato intentaríamos
despedir a los menos productivos verdad
sin embargo con la actual legislación
despedir un boomers sea productivo o no
puede costar unos doscientos mil euros
mientras que despedir un millenials sabe
prácticamente gratis conclusión antes de
despedir un bumerdés pedimos a un
millenials y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando no puede ser que todo esto se
ha hecho a propósito de verdad estamos
diciendo aquí en visual político que hay
una conspiración de todo el sistema
político español para exprimir a los
jóvenes a favor de los mayores de 50
años pues lo cierto es que sólo habéis
visto el principio atentos porque ahora
llega la auténtica guinda del pastel
habéis oído hablar alguna vez de la
redistribución de la riqueza de verdad
pensabais que en españa pagan más
impuestos quienes más tienen
pues atentos
i
[Música]
saturno devora a sus hijos
voy a daros un ejemplo muy simbólico
pero muy ilustrativo vamos a hablar de
pañales en españa' un paquete de pañales
para bebés cuesta unos 14 euros dentro
de este precio por supuesto está
incluido el iva correspondiente que como
ya sabéis es del 21% pero como también
sabréis muchos no solo los bebés usan
pañales mucha gente mayor tiene
incontinencia urinaria y también
necesita pañales es decir que existen
los llamados pañales para adultos pues
bien cuanto diríais que cuesta un
paquete de pañales para adultos en
españa catorce euros diez euros pues la
respuesta es cero euros tal cual como lo
y si eres un jubilado español el estado
cubre el coste total de los pañales tal
y como lo oís y creedme que esto no es
un ejemplo aislado si veis este vídeo
desde españa seguramente penséis que
quien menos dinero gana es quien menos
impuestos paga verdad a fin de cuentas
eso es lo que siempre nos han contado en
el colegio sin embargo y si echamos un
vistazo a este gráfico
[Música]
podéis frotar a los ojos el quintil más
pobre de los españoles paga más
impuestos que los otros dos quintiles de
hecho la diferencia entre los impuestos
que paga el quintil más pobre y el más
rico es de un simple 10% y si ese
quintil más pobre es también el quintil
más joven todo esto se explica por
impuestos como el iva o las cotizaciones
a la seguridad social y por cierto estos
datos son del gobierno a estas alturas
seguramente muchos estáis realmente
indignados pero todavía no hemos
terminado porque la pregunta no es sólo
cuántos impuestos se pagan sino hacia
dónde va todo ese dinero me gustaría
deciros que el dinero de los impuestos
va a pagar carreteras colegios y
hospitales pero la realidad es muy
distinta la realidad es que la principal
partida de gasto en españa son las
pensiones para que os hagáis una idea
las pensiones suponen un 36 por ciento
de todos los presupuestos del estado en
el año 2021 y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando muchos las pensiones el gran
problema de todo el mundo occidental
como ya dijimos la semana pasada en
visual político tanto en españa como en
muchos otros países europeos tienen un
problema enorme para pagar las pensiones
sin embargo españa también tiene algo
muy pero que muy peculiar atentos a esta
gráfica
[Música]
aquí podéis ver como españa tiene una de
las pensiones más generosas del mundo
por ejemplo los jubilados en reinounido
cobran una pensión pública que es de
media el 24 por ciento del sueldo que
ganaban cuando estaban en el trabajo en
alemania hablamos de un 50 por ciento
pues bien en españa estamos en el 83 por
ciento dicho de otra forma en españa si
tienes menos de 25 años cobras una media
de 700 57 euros al mes pero si eres
jubilado cobras una media de mil 185
euros al mes además tienes toda clase de
ayudas sociales beneficios fiscales y
todo lo que has ido ahorrando a lo largo
de tu vida es decir que el estado del
bienestar a duras penas sirve para limar
las diferencias entre ricos y pobres o
lo que es lo mismo entre boomers y
millennials no me creéis pues atentos a
este otro gráfico
como podéis ver irlanda que por cierto
es un país famoso por tener impuestos
bajos es curiosamente el país donde el
estado juega un papel más activo en
reducir la pobreza españa sin embargo
está entre los cuatro estados que menos
pobreza reducen y ojo porque en españa
todos los políticos están prácticamente
en la línea de seguir por el mismo
camino el gobierno sube las pensiones un
0 9% y las mínimas un 18 por ciento para
2021 supondrá un coste de casi 1500
millones de euros casado preguntas y se
congelarán sueldos y avisa las pensiones
no se tocan y estas dos noticias tienen
como consecuencia esta otra el gobierno
sube la cuota de autónomos hasta 24
euros en medio de una caída en picado de
la actividad económica habéis oído bien
en españa ahora mismo se están subiendo
los impuestos y subiendo las pensiones
es decir subidas que afectan en gran
medida a las rentas más bajas dicho de
otra forma a los millennials todo este
dinero a quién va a parar pues a las
rentas más altas es decir a los boomers
pensado cuando hablamos de los boomers
hablamos del grupo más numeroso y más
influyente de todo el país los mayores
de 50 años suponen el 40 por ciento de
la población total y tienen tasas de
participación electoral mucho más altas
que los más jóvenes es decir que son el
grupo de votantes a los que ningún
político quiere molestar es más casi
todas las campañas políticas van
dirigidas hacia ellos pero no creáis que
sólo hablamos de campañas políticas
también las empresas de gran consumo
están empezando a tomar nota así que si
vivís en españa ya os podéis acostumbrar
a ver muchos anuncios dirigidos a este
grupo los seniors son los verdaderos
consumidores del futuro así que ahora la
pregunta es para vosotros queréis que
algún día se arreglarán estas
desigualdades e incentivos puede tener
un político para poner a régimen a ese
saturno para que deje de devorar a sus
hijos y lo que es más importante que
salidas le quedan un millennial en
españa' podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios y como siempre no
olvidéis que aquí en visual político
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas
así que suscribiros a este canal y dada
la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo
[Música]